you are likely already familiar with
finding the area between cars and in
fact if you're not I encourage you to
review that on Khan Academy for example
we could find this yellow area using a
definite integral but what we're going
to do in this video is do something even
more interesting we're gonna find the
volume of shapes where the base is
defined in some way by the area between
two curves and in this video we're gonna
think about a shape and I'm Li draw it
in three dimensions so let me draw this
over again but with a little bit of
perspective so let's make this the
y-axis so that's the y-axis this is my
x-axis that is my x-axis this is the
line y is equal to six right over there
y is equal to six and this dotted line
we could just draw it like this
and so this would be the point x equals
two and then the graph of y is equal to
four times the natural log of 3 minus x
would look something like this looks
something like this and so this region
is this region but it's going to be the
base of a three dimensional shape where
any cross section if I were to take a
cross section right over here is going
to be a square so whatever this length
is we also go that much high and so the
cross section is a square right over
there the cross section right over here
is going to be a square whatever the
difference between these two functions
is that's also how high we are going to
go this length which is six at this
point this is also going to be the
height it is going to be a square it's
gonna be quite big we have to scroll
down so we can draw the whole thing
roughly at the right proportion so it
looks something like this this should be
a square that's gonna look something
like this and so the whole shape would
look would look something like this
would look something like that and try
to shade that in a little bit so that
you can appreciate it a little bit more
but hopefully you get the idea and some
of you might be excited and some of you
might be a little intimidated well hey
I've been dealing with the two
dimensions for so long what's going on
with these three dimensions but you'll
quickly appreciate that you already have
the powers of integration to solve this
and to do that we just have to break up
the shape into a bunch of these you
could view them as these little square
tiles that have some depth to them so
let's make that into a little tile this
one into it that also has some depth to
it you could even I could draw multiple
places you could view it as a break it
up into these things that have a very
small depth that we could call DX and we
know how to figure out what their volume
is what would be the volume of one of
these things well it would be the depth
times the area times the surface area of
this cross-section right over here moved
in a different color so what would be
the area that I am shading in in pink
right over here
well that area is going to be the base
length squared what's the base length
well it's the difference between these
two functions it is going to be 6 minus
our bottom function is 4 times the
natural log of 3 minus X and so that
would just give us that length but if we
square it we get this entire area we get
that entire area you square it and then
you multiply it times the depth you
multiply it times the depth now you have
the volume of just this little section
right over here and I think you might
see where this is going
now what if you were to add up all of
these from x equals 0 to x equals 2 well
then you would have the volume of the
entire thing this is the power of the
definite integral so we could just
integrate from x equals 0 to x equals 2
from x equals 0 to x equals 2 if you
drew where these intersect our base you
would say all right this thing right
over here would be this thing right over
here where it's DX instead of just
multiplying DX times the difference
between these functions we're going to
square the difference of these functions
because we're visualizing this
three-dimensional shape the surface area
of this 3 dimensional shape as opposed
to just the height of this little
rectangle and if you were to evaluate
this integral you would indeed get the
volume of this this kind of pedestal
horn look
thing this is not an easy definite
integral to evaluate by hand but we can
actually use a calculator for that and
so we can hit math and then hit choice
number nine for a definite integral and
then we just have to input everything
we're going from zero till two of and
then we have let me open parenthesis cuz
I'm gonna square everything six minus
four times the natural log of X or
actually the natural log of 3 minus X
and so let me close the parentheses on
the natural log part and then if I close
the parentheses on this whole thing I
want to then square it and then I'm
integrating with respect to X enter I
got approximately twenty six point two
seven
so approximately 26 point two seven and
this is a volume here so if we thought
about units it would be in our units
cubed or cubic units